over the the course of 20 years i had
made so many mistakes so the idea
started with like how can i translate
those mistakes into you know learnings
that anyone could really apply so that
not everyone has to go through the same
hard lessons but beyond that right the
idea was we really had to make sure it
was generalizable to
organizations whether they were startups
or larger organizations and so this is
where you know i started testing this
approach with
different kinds of companies different
industries etc welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders i
am joined today by radhika dot author of
radical product thinking the new mindset
for innovating smarter
she's an entrepreneur and product leader
she has participated in four
acquisitions two of which were companies
that she founded she has built products
in industries including broadcasting
media advertising technology government
consumer robotics and wine
dot advises organizations from high-tech
startups to government agencies on
building radical products that create a
fundamental change instead of optimizing
the status quo she also teaches
entrepreneurship and innovation at
northeastern university's the moore
mckeem school of business
radica dot welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you today
i'm good thank you so much for having me
on michael
thank you very very much for being here
radhika i'm so excited to talk to you
about this idea of radical product
thinking and and you know your your
whole journey is so fascinating around
that and you know as i'm looking at my
personal journey and that of my friends
and colleagues you know one of the big
questions that we keep asking ourselves
is how do we create these radically
innovative products and you know
like like steve jobs and bill gates and
sergey and larry page and
what's happening you know with with
product
design thinking radical mindsets and
you know you writing a book that is
coming out tomorrow you're teaching at
northeastern business school
you yourself studied bachelors and
masters at mit a part of four
acquisitions and startups that are
ranging
amongst very very different
categories and so i'm really excited to
dive deep into you know your own
background into the in these 20 minutes
as well as the book that is coming out
and talking a little bit about product
development and and creativity and
innovation and so radica maybe we can
start off tell me a little bit about you
know your own curiosity and and what is
it really that that you're so deeply
curious about
um
the quest for this um
the quest for this methodology and this
approach right it all started because um
of my own experiences having been an
entrepreneur um so you know my first
startup was something that i started
along with um a few other school um
classmates um so we were still in dorm
rooms when we started our first startup
and you know one of the first things
that happened was we had raised money
but we caught what i call chronic
diseases um one of the diseases we
caught was hero syndrome um and this was
back in 2000 and by the way you know 20
years later i still find that those
diseases that we've caught back then
they're still just as common so hero
syndrome is the disease at one of the
seven diseases i mentioned in the book
where you know here is syndrome is what
we catch when we're so focused on scale
on being big um on this idea of go
you know go big or go home um
what happens is we conflate um finding
funding with success or we conflate uh
scale
with having a successful product
um and this is exactly what we ran into
in my first startup um and the quest you
know for building better products really
came about because
i was driven by the question you know is
it that there are just a few people
who can build world-changing products
and the rest of us are kind of doomed to
just learning from trial and error or
can we actually build successful
products very systematically because one
of the things that you know um in in
silicon valley or just in the startup
world what we keep hearing is the way
you build products is iterate fast try
lots of things and see what works and
you know that's how you that's kind of
the recipe for building successful
products and i realized that that was
not quite the right approach um it's
almost like you know there are a few
startups that hit jackpot by taking this
approach
but it's it's the equivalent of the
strategy of uh you know let's play the
slot machines to get funding kind of
strategy you know it just doesn't work
um statistically speaking um and so what
we need is a more systematic approach
and that's how this came came about
and so
you transition from you know building
companies and being an entrepreneur to
thinking about these things more
holistically and critically you know
what does that transition mean to you
you know that did you see that as
complementary to the entrepreneurial
side of you this strategic thinking you
know now teaching in business school was
it a specific trigger that led you down
this path to you know go you know 30 000
feet in there and try to map the
landscape and and not just take your own
case studies but but merge with all
those around you well what happened
there
yeah it was um
you know as we started thinking about
how we build successful products it was
something that we needed to make sure
was generalizable that it wasn't just
something very specific to my own case
studies or my own examples um and what i
found was that you know i had over the
course of about 20 years learned just a
lot of hard lessons on how to build good
products um and it was you know over the
course of 20 years i had made so many
mistakes so the idea started with like
how can i translate those mistakes into
you know learnings that anyone could
really apply so that not everyone has to
go through the same hard lessons but
beyond that right the idea was we really
had to make sure it was generalizable to
organizations whether they were startups
or larger organizations and so this is
where you know i started testing this
approach with um different kinds of
companies different industries etc
um and what i realized was you know in
terms of building successful products
it's not that
we cannot use iteration
i'm not against the idea of iteration
altogether um in fact i use lean startup
i use agile i find these methodologies
highly useful right it's useful for
feedback driven
execution but the analogy i like to use
is um
you know we use iteration to drive fast
but driving fast is only useful when you
actually know where you're going um and
so this is why the strategic approach
really needs to be combined with it
reading fast
and that's kind of what this does until
now all the methodologies business books
etc that we've uh that that we've really
internalized right all of those
methodologies mostly talk about how we
can move fast um they help us
use iteration and use the speed um or
use the tactics of trial and error how
can we fail fast learn fast better right
um but what we haven't had so far is a
very clear methodology for defining a
clear vision um for crafting a strategy
basically methodology so that your
iterations and your execution can be
driven by a vision and strategy and
that's the gap that radical product
thinking fills so in fact it pairs
really well with lean and agile and
that's how i use it with organizations
i love it okay so so let's dig deep into
into radical you know erratical thinking
what's happening there with with product
development and building great products
and and more specifically you know in
the system that you've developed and how
that you know translates into some
examples that we see either you know in
today's world the world that we had
before
yeah maybe i'll share first of all what
i mean by the difference between being
vision driven versus iteration led right
and i think that's a good starting point
because it really illustrates why do we
even need to think differently um
you know let's look at the example of
the tesla model 3 versus you know the
chevy bolt right
the difference between these two cars
and kind of the vision that was behind
these two cars and then what that meant
in terms of the end result i think that
really illustrates the difference
between vision driven versus iteration
led so
there is a famous auto expert sandy
monroe who took apart these cars to
really study them and compare them and
so he opens up this chevy bolt and you
know what you see under the hood is that
it looks very much like a traditional
gas car
um and in fact you know if you look at
their cooling systems there are three
cooling systems to cool different parts
of the car one for the engine the
battery and one for the cabin right
now you compare this to the tesla model
3.
but when you open the hood it looks
nothing like a traditional gas car um
and if you look at the cooling system
specifically right they have one system
which they call the super bottle that
does both heating and cooling for the
entire car
um now one of the things that the um
that this auto expert talked about is
you know in detroit they've always
talked about having one cooling system
but the problem is right
every calling every one of these three
elements was someone's fiefdom in
detroit and so
they really didn't put it all together
into this one system um
the whole of this chevy bolt is
basically a small iteration
of what detroit already knew which was
gas cars
on the other hand if you look at the
tesla um you know sandy monroe describes
it as being revolutionary different and
um
the sales speak for themselves the
tesla model 3 is outselling you know the
bmw
3 series the mercedes c-class plus the
audi a4 combined right um whereas the
chevy bolt is doing okay it's doing well
um and if you think about kind of where
it all starts let's look at the vision
that drives these two cars that's where
the fundamental difference starts so the
tesla model 3 is driven by a vision for
the change that um
the company wanted to bring about which
was to create an affordable car that
didn't require a compromise from the
driver to go green
whereas if you look at the chevy bolt
right there was a very different vision
that led to it it was driven by a
business goal and that business goal was
beating tesla model 3 to market
with a range of over 200k uh 200 miles
um and so these two very different uh
visions one is a vision for change in
the world the other is a vision for a
corporate goal
those two visions led to a very
different end product and this is what i
mean by
what i want us to do differently right
instead of a business goal um
that's driving every aspect of your
product what we really need to start
with is a vision for the change we want
to see in the world and then we very
systematically translate that so that
every part of our product reflects that
vision
and what happens today right is we
haven't had this methodology to be very
systematic so that there's no break in
the chain between the vision all the way
to your everyday actions and to every
element of your product um and that
because that's been missing
whenever there is that break in the
chain
that's where product disease is creeping
and so
this whole radical product thinking
approach helps you do each of those
steps from vision to strategy to how
that translates into everyday activities
uh it helps you do all of that
systematically so your product
becomes your mechanism to create the
change you want to see in the world
right and i think that one of the things
that i'm you know immediately thinking
about is you know i guess that one of
the implications you know what you're
saying is that you know through an
iterative process it doesn't matter how
iterative and how agile you are if the
vision is not there if you're not think
if you're not innovative in your vision
then then you're then you're out of the
game but you'll iterate on the wrong
vision and you won't end up as as a
winner at the end and so i love that
example now
let's focus then on on the vision aspect
how do you actually you know
create an environment in which you can
build visionary products and and have
that type of mentality
i think the first thing is um we have to
unlearn some of the things that we've
learned until now right things that have
been so deeply embedded in us
the first thing where we need to start
is what we mean by good vision uh until
now everything that we've always learned
about a good vision is that it has to be
a beehive that's the most common term we
use in the vc world right um but it has
to be a big hairy audacious goal
we say that a good vision has to be
short a slogan so people can remember it
and i want us to really step away from
all of those
conventional ideas
the reason is this when you have just a
beehive for a vision it's just not
detailed enough to be able to drive your
iterations
and so instead in the radical way
we have to have a very detailed vision
that
helps you define the problem statement
and your solution to the problem so the
way to do that is to answer five
questions the who what why when and how
um so the first question is you know
whose world are you trying to change it
can't just be everyone or like consumers
or you know businesses it has to be a
very specifically identifiable group of
people
um
what is their problem meaning what does
their world look like today
and what's their solution that they're
using today
the third question and this one is
probably the most important one to me is
why does that status quo
need changing why is it completely
unacceptable because the reality is
right unless the status quo is
unacceptable maybe there's no reason for
your product to exist
the fourth question then is when will
you know that you've arrived meaning
what does the world look like when you
can say mission accomplished
and then finally this is where we can
talk about our own product or technology
the last question is how will you bring
that about um and that's where you can
say you know here's what your product is
going to do
and so in the radical product thinking
way
i use these five questions but in a fill
in the blank statement so that we don't
play vision bingo and you know deal with
buzzwords instead we just focus on
answering these questions and fill in
the blank statement so if you're like
i'm happy to share an example of what
that would sound like
yeah a 100 yes
okay so i'll use the startup um that i
had as an example so it would read like
this today when amateur wine drinkers
want to find wines that they're likely
to like
they have to try attractive looking wine
bottles or wines that are on sale
this is unacceptable because it leads to
so many disappointments
we envision a world where finding wines
you like is as easy as finding movies
you like on netflix
we're bringing about this world through
a recommendations algorithm that matches
wines to your taste
and an operational setup that delivers
these wines to your door
so
this is the entire vision statement
right and i realize it sounds more like
an essay than
a slogan but here's the power of it i
had told you absolutely nothing about my
startup but hopefully you know sharing
this vision statement told you exactly
what we were doing and why we were doing
it
yes that is what you want in a radical
vision
a hundred percent no and it makes a lot
of sense now
once you have that what are sort of the
side effects of this so now that you
have this radical vision
then is this does this sort of become
you know the the vision for the for the
for the company that is also helping
align the employees is this you know at
what point do you think this is you know
a critical step for a startup to do is
in the beginning is it as they're
finding product market fit in there and
they're iterating on a bunch of
different different problem sets what
what is the sweet spot for this
oh i'm so glad you asked this um because
it's that's the other conventional
wisdom that we learned right that your
vision is unchanging you set your vision
at the beginning and it never changes
and that's one of the most important
things right the challenge because as a
startup the reality is you're learning
so much every single day so the way i
use this with startups is you know when
you start out
use this as a stake in the ground write
out a vision statement saying this is
what you think the problem is
and what you think the world should look
like but the reality is right a month
later if you're an early stage startup
you might discover that you were
completely wrong a month ago right but
then go back and revisit that statement
and you can rewrite the answers to those
questions and you have a new vision
statement but the most important thing
is you know instead of just pivoting
left and right and catching the product
disease pivotitis um you're really going
to be able to align your team because
you're helping them understand
what was it that we learned what is no
longer true and what is the new vision
and so you do this you know as often as
you need to the reality is as an early
stage startup you might want to revisit
your vision every month because your
pace of learning is just so incredibly
fast um as if you're a mature company
you know you might need to do this every
six months maybe every year or so um but
that
frequency
is kind of
super important and you have to decide
what's right for you but we have to
begin to treat our vision statement as a
hypothesis and then our execution and
our iterations they're all
there to help us prove out this vision
and our strategy etc
and that that makes a lot of sense and
radical i really want to thank you for
joining these 20 minutes by one these 20
minutes went by very very fast and i
really appreciate you taking the time
and to be here with me and
congratulations on the launch of a new
new book by the time this airs the book
will have been out already and so i'm
excited to purchase and read it myself
so thank you very very much and now i
want to take you back for just a couple
minutes back to you know to your
childhood and about yourself you know
growing up what really sparked your
curiosity where what really you know
made you curious about the world
um what made me curious about the world
i think that was just a way of being for
me um it was
being curious about the things around me
just wanting to learn more
i think what was also deeply profoundly
influential that shaped me was living in
different places you know i moved around
a lot as a child i lived in different
cities in india but then i also moved to
south africa this was actually during um
the transition from apartheid to
democracy um all of these things really
shaped my world view and the desire to
just learn more about people cultures
and so on um and that's part of me today
i i love it and if you look today on
what inspires you in the work that you
do whether it's you know northeastern or
whether it's with the startups that you
work with or or anything like that what
what really inspires you
what really inspires me is this desire
that we can build products that also
embrace responsibility you know we've
learned for so long that the way you
build products just try what works in
the market and
build it a fine product market fit you
know we don't think so much about well
how are our products affecting society
and in the book i talk about you know
five different types of digital
pollution that i've realized
that the world is dealing with today
you know i think if we think about
environmental pollution and how the
industrial boom led to environmental
pollution we're facing something very
similar where in the digital era
we've created digital pollution
and we need to build products that don't
affect society negatively
and in the book i really talk about how
we can take this hippocratic oath of
product
and that inspires me because you know if
i think about a lot of the generation
today
you know i hear kids talk about how they
don't want to bring new life into the
world
because they feel like it wouldn't be
good for the world or good for
their kids to experience um
the hardships in the world right like i
was thinking about how growing up i
always felt like technology was going to
make the world a better place
and a lot of this new generation doesn't
feel that way anymore
and so it's a tremendous responsibility
that i think you know people who are
graduating college now face that we need
to build products that make the world a
better place um so that for the next
generation too they can feel like
technology is creating a better world um
and that inspires me we have the ability
to do that we can take responsibility
and build products that also
make the world a little more like the
one we want to live in
i love it and what are a few words that
you would use to describe yourself
um
okay let's think um i think three words
um the best is um thoughtful or mindful
um because i realize that building
products gives us a superpower
the second is
being vision driven
i think it took me a long time to become
more vision driven
but i think
as as i have kind of grown in my career
i realized that i have a vision for what
i want to do um and and i've
increasingly learned to be more vision
driven
um and i guess the last one is
sheer
persistence um so i'm extremely
persistent um and and you kind of have
to be like that i guess as an
entrepreneur um so yeah i guess those
are three words to describe me um so
thoughtful persistent and vision driven
i love it veronica thank you so so much
this is so great and i really appreciate
you taking the time to be here and share
this this with me and and it leaves me
with great optimism so thank you very
much congratulations on the new book and
i can't wait to read it myself thank you
thank you so much for having me this was
such a pleasure michael